how's gone my feedback I'm fairly
certain I just found the best game of
all time it's called this game has a
very very complex control scheme you
press this button and that's it yeah
oh nice luggage ok how do we do this how
do we do in it no yes yes oh so close so
close no what are you doing
okay we're Argentina here this should be
good
yes yeah Argentina and your nips that's
a weed Oh what slippery
oh god huge goals in a beach ball come
on what are you doing goalkeeper okay
this should be fine right
awful [ __ ] Shh this is really hard man
there we go please I'm always the one
that makes my own goal okay what did
they do what is he doing
don't breakdance fantastic goalkeeping
we've seen here today oh my God he's
just show so much energy on their break
no you can break down your life but you
can't oh come on that's an American
football what are you doing here
get out of here get off my turf nice fun
flavor yeah oh god no the beach ball
again
oh god what are you going wait no oh god
yes it's coming it's coming
jump no ok ok wait he's looking perfect
he can't move they can't score I have if
I don't win this oh my god don't don't
[ __ ] this out
I don't oh no no no no no no what what
are you talking about first five wins
alright this time I'll win wait doc
goddammit
buddy stop it's so hard don't jump on
him what do you fit you
what kind of tactic is is Oh seems to
work and that's what it is
Oh what he did yes it is love
breakdancing Disney huge goals really ya
know what yeah a bad bird come on baby
Oh Oh small goal yeah come on we can do
this what why don't they have any heads
I'm okay with it
whoa Jesus Wow
American football come on if we win this
one we win everything come on just kind
of yeah all right
best out of three come on yes let's do
this oh that blockage come on baby come
on the front free okay the Tower of Pisa
all the tactics here tonight never seen
such fantastic display of sportsmanship
Oh God
my but scored come on that's bull crap
oh god it's slippery what what is that
[Music]
come on come on Oh fan come on we can't
lose this
Nik yeah come on this still a chance oh
yes come on come on
I don't want Wyatt
maybe it's amusing whether this game is
making it so intense all right whoever
wins this one wins everything for [ __ ]
sake yeah yeah good job great [ __ ]
job yes all that blockage seriously what
are they doing fisting each other Oh Oh
God
go get out someone get out someone get
out Oh Oh calm down pear juice it's a
video game
[Music]
alpha [ __ ] shut up
where is he going i front-flip over him
oh my god go go go now
whoa Jesus okay awful funny him versus
Javon up I'll let you get oven ah [ __ ]
it I'm gonna win this it's the last
thing I'll ever do oh yes yes yes all
right
[Music]
Oh God we have to win this one
Josh come on one more one more please
wait for them to [ __ ] up I think some
point
oh my goalkeeper is going for it go for
goalkeeper man go free goalkeeper men
what are you doing goalkeeper Matt yeah
Tyrone what are you doing Tyrone don't
sis in his face oh oh yeh I can't I
can't [ __ ] up now what are you doing I
will I will piss on your face are you
serious I can't this [ __ ] cake this
is pretty much soccer is it pretty
accurate for the cup simulator right
here
what are they doing you're not a scizor
man you're not I can't [ __ ] that okay
you know what
shake this game out it's free it's
awesome play with yourself play with
your friend to play with yourself
explore your body what do I care
thank you for liking and commenting on
this video breasts and I'll see you and
whatever next we're gonna play ro finish